Dans quelques jours, Thomas Pesquet sera là haut, à 400 km au dessus de nos têtes. A bord de la station spatiale internationale.
Ça donne à la fois le vertige, et ça fait rêver.
Comment une fusée de plus de 500 tonnes
peut-elle s’arracher du sol ?
Je vous explique tout avant le décollage.
Allez c'est parti !
Cette fois en plus des expériences qu’il va mener à bord de l’Iss, Thomas Pesquet occupera le poste de commandant:
une première pour un Français.
Et voici l’équipage avec lequel il va voyager : une Américaine, un Américain et un Japonais.
Ils vont prendre place à bord du vaisseau Crew dragon qui sera fixé au sommet d'une fusée Falcon 9.
En présentant la photo de l’équipage sur ses réseaux, Thomas Pesquet a parlé des 4 fantastiques…
Et il nous a même invités à deviner leur pouvoirs respectifs…
Alors avant de vous expliquer comment il va grimper jusque-là, un peu d’Histoire…
La première tentative connue remonte au tout début du 16ème siècle ! Le Chinois Wan Hu,
dont on sait que les prédécesseurs ont inventé la poudre, avait équipé une chaise de 47 mini-fusées.
Concrètement, de simples tubes de carton remplis de poudre. Une fois installé,
il donna l’ordre d’allumer toutes les fusées en même temps, pour décoller. Son objectif était alors d’atteindre la Lune.
Comme vous pouvez le deviner, tout cela ne s’est pas très bien terminé pour lui…
Et maintenant, direction les archives...
Pendant très longtemps la conquête spatiale reste du domaine de la science fiction…
En 1865 paraît le roman de Jules Vernes « De la Terre à la Lune », en 1902 Georges Méliès,
le père des effets spéciaux réalise « le voyage dans la Lune ».
En fait, il faut attendre Constantin Tsiolkovski - c’est pas facile à dire - pour que la technologie spatiale décolle vraiment.
Ce professeur de mathématiques, est le premier à concevoir dès 1903 un schéma de fusée moderne
avec ses différents étages largables au fur et à mesure de l’élévation de l’engin.
Une technique toujours utilisée aujourd’hui !
En 1935, l’Autrichien Hermann Oberth réussit le premier lancement au monde d’une fusée à combustible liquide.
Les Russes et les Américains s’appuieront d'ailleurs sur cette technologie pour lancer ensuite leurs fusées…
Ce sont les soviétiques qui les premiers vont réussir à mettre un satellite en orbite, Spoutnik en 1957…
puis à envoyer le premier homme dans l’espace : Youri Gagarine le 12 avril 1961. On vient de fêter les 60 ans.
Il y restera 108 mn… avant de revenir sur Terre sain et sauf. On est loin des 6 mois que durent en général les missions à bord de l’ISS.
Et Laïka, t'as oublié de parler de Laïka !
C’est vrai ! La chienne Laïka est le premier être vivant mis en orbite en 1957.
Spoutnik, Youri Gagarine, l’équipage de la mission Apollo 11 composé de Neil Armstrong, Michael Collins et Buzz Aldrin…
Voilà des noms qui ont marqué la conquête spatiale…
Bon... Assez d'Histoire, quand est-ce qu’on décolle ?
Je redescends sur terre et je me lance.
Alors en 60 ans, on a fait beaucoup de progrès. La fusée Falcon 9 qui va propulser le vaisseau « Crew Dragon »
à bord duquel va se trouver Thomas Pesquet est un bijou de technologie.
Pour info, c’est la première fois que Thomas Pesquet volera à bord de ce vaisseau propulsé par ce lanceur.
La fois précédente, il avait effectué le voyage à bord de la capsule Soyouz lancée par une fusée du même nom.
Quoi qu’il en soit, les principes physiques mis en œuvre pour faire décoller un engin de cette taille,
n’ont pas changé depuis les débuts de la conquête spatiale.
On utilise toujours le principe d’action-réaction. La 3ème loi de Newton pour les connaisseurs. J’explique :
lorsqu’un corps A exerce une force sur un corps B, ce corps B exerce une force sur le corps A d’intensité égale,
mais dans le sens opposé.
Démonstration : quand j’appuie avec jambes j’exerce une force contre le mur, c’est l’action…
par réaction une force identique de même intensité s’exerce dans le sens opposé.
Four... Three... Two... One...
Pour faire décoller une fusée on utilise le même principe. Mais on ne pousse pas avec les pieds, on pousse avec des gaz.
Suivez-moi dans le jardin, je vais vous montrer.
On s’est tous amusés à gonfler un ballon de baudruche...
Et à lâcher l’embout.
L’air s’échappe dans un sens et le ballon part dans l’autre…
Bon... je sais, comme ça ce n’est pas très visible.
Maintenant, si le ballon est fixé à une glissière, une paille par exemple, et que la paille glisse le long d’un fil tendu à la verticale.
Eh bien c’est beaucoup plus flagrant, vous allez le voir.
Selon le principe d’action-réaction,  l’air qui s’échappe par l’embout exerce une force dirigée vers le bas…
Et par réaction, une force identique s’exerce vers le haut. Prêts ?
C'est parti !
C'est clair comme de l'eau de roche.
Pour faire décoller une fusée, on utilise le même principe à ceci près que ce n’est pas de l’air qui est expulsé mais des gaz.
La fusée éjecte très rapidement une masse très importante de gaz issue de la combustion du carburant.
L’échappement de ces gaz génère une force dirigée vers le bas. Et par réaction, une force identique est générée vers le haut.
C’est cette force, qu’on appelle la poussée, qui fait décoller la fusée Falcon 9
C'est un engin d'environ 70 mètres de hauteur et de 550 tonnes… À la sortie du moteur, la tuyère,
cette partie située en bas qui ressemble à un entonnoir à l’envers, force les gaz à s’échapper vers le bas.
Ce dégagement à très haute pression fournit une poussée si forte, près de 800 tonnes, qu’il fait décoller la fusée.
Exactement comme notre ballon il y a quelques minutes ! En nettement plus puissant, tout de même !
Pour rendre les choses un peu plus faciles, les ingénieurs ont depuis longtemps trouvé une astuce.
La NASA fait décoller ses fusées depuis Cap Canaveral en Floride. Quant à l’ESA, l’agence spatiale européenne,
elle fait décoller les siennes depuis Kourou en Guyane…
ça aide énormément. Je vous raconte pourquoi dans ma prochaine vidéo…
D’ici là vous pouvez observer le ciel. Et en consultant les sites de la Nasa ou de l’ESA
vous pouvez connaître les heures auxquelles l’ISS passe au-dessus de nos têtes.
Profitez-en, et à très bientôt, pour un nouveau décollage.